alors madame monsieur votre ville a fait
la une de l'actualité il ya quelques
jours et j'imagine qu'elle s'en serait
bien passé puisque japy peugeot japy
entreprise historique de valentigney a
déposé le bilan 250 emplois sont en jeu
que peut faire que doit faire un maire
confronté à une telle situation
philippe gautier il ya deux aspects il
ya l'aspect économique sur lequel un
maire ne peut vraiment pas faire
grand-chose 10 f1 dire qu'un maire a
tout pouvoir sur une entreprise c'est
faux de dire ça par contre ce qui est
important est ce qu'il faut accompagner
c'est le côté social qui arrive derrière
tout ça assez comment peugeot japy
le choix a été fait de déposer le bilan
mais comment peugeot japy aps rebondir
comment on peut accompagner au mieux sur
la reconversion du site industriel
comment on peut vraiment suivre les
personnes parce que beaucoup sont issus
de la ville donc comment on peut les
accompagner
quels sont les synergies qu'on doit
mettre en place parce que au delà de ça
c'est une certainement pas un échelon de
la ville que ça doit se passer
il ya un échelon au niveau de pma
surtout qu'à une compétence économique
avec sacem
je précise pays de montbéliard
agglomération c'est l'intercommunalité
du fait des baisses de 72 communes
cet exemple c'est ça ce sont deux
communes depuis peu grâce à lui notre
voilà donc à la scène une société
économie mixte qui peut intervenir aussi
sur les bâtiments mais à travers ça
c'est quel est le projet parce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut quand même
espérer grâce au savoir faire et vous
l'avez dit cet historique de peugeot
japy
il y a un réel savoir faire je vais très
souvent les voir et il ya un parc
machines qui est exceptionnel donc
aujourd'hui c'est comment on fait la
médiation parce qu'ils sont sûrs
aujourd'hui un marché qui sont sur des
boîtes de vitesses mécanique c'est
comment fait-on pour aller sur deûle
automatique comment fait-on pourquoi pas
aller vers de l'électrique claude
françois sommer sur japy peugeot et le
rôle du maire confronté aux difficultés
économiques des entreprises de sa
commune même si la commune n'a pas la
compétence économique qu'on parle bien
de l'intercommunalité l'intercommunalité
c'est l'ensemble des communes
donc monsieur gautier est vice président
donc à partir de là c'est bien main dans
la main comme une intercommunalité
effectivement qui devra apporter les
réponses en direction de cette industrie
qui a besoin d'une reconversion qui a
déjà démarré notamment la modernisation
de son outil de production qui a déjà
qualifié ces salariés pour pouvoir
rebondir face à ses difficultés
économiques
mais surtout ce que je pense aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'on peut déplorer de la part de
notre intercommunalité
non monsieur gautier bien vice président
c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu d'anticipation
de ses difficultés
aujourd'hui l'intercommunalité et comme
les communes agissent en pompier quand
il ya des difficultés
comment demain on est en mesure de
construire une interne aux mines à loyer
vous anticipez c'est en quelque sorte
facile à dire une fois que on arrive
dans le mur comment vous auriez fait en
comment vous auriez anticipées je pense
qu'aujourd'hui pma à des outils
nécessaires pour avoir une veille
permanente au niveau de l'industrie pour
anticiper un des projets de reconversion
les difficultés de trésorerie c'est le
cas pour peugeot japy qui avait
sollicité pma en matière de trésorerie
qui n'a pas eu la réponse en temps et en
heure sur un million d'euros qui aurait
permis
je ne dis pas non pas d'arriver à ce
dépôt de bilan mais au moins de le
retarder de permettre au moins qu'on
sorte de cette période de confinement
pour pouvoir anticiper ces difficultés
un qui arrivait je vous laisse répondre
philippe beauté non non c'est pas exact
alors oui ce qui est exact si je suis
effectivement vice président de
l'agglomération aujourd'hui de pma non
les discussions bien eu lieu et que je
japy preuve en est des 2008 rappelez
vous la ville morte
initié par la ville avec tous les élus
que ce soit du côté de belfort qui sont
venus et là des jeunes l'ont déjà sonné
à faire une alarme et nous avons
travaillé avec le repreneur farinia mais
aujourd'hui que farina n'injecte pas et
lui même nager kt pas le million d'euros
pour pouvoir rebondir
ça ne relève pas de la compétence de
l'agglomération par contre aidées sur
les bâtiments oui je suis d'accord avec
vous ça pue la l'agglomération a son
rôle à jouer
la veille
que peugeot japy ce qu'il faut le savoir
c'est qu'aujourd'hui s'ils ont perdu 20%
de leur marché par rapport que bosh
s'est retirée par rapport à gm s'est
retiré ses des affaires propres à
l'entreprise et pma n'a pas avoir grand
chose sur ces marchés
je précise un japy à pour quasiment
client unique que peu jour mérogis est
exaltant le 9 juin dernier madame
monsieur l'une de nos équipes est allé
en reportage à valentigney et a
rencontré l'un des syndicalistes de
l'usiné peugeot japy
voici ce qu'il leur a confié on est
désespéré ça fait trois ans que qu'on
nous mène en bateau de tous les côtés on
nous promet monts et merveilles et puis
ce qu'on constate à la fin c'est que la
boîte elle ressemble plus à un cimetière
de l'emploi qu'autre chose quoi elles il
y avait 500 salariés et quand cette
boîte a été reprise aujourd'hui elle en
comporte plus que 246 ont sonné la
moitié
qu'en sera-t-il demain est-ce qu'on va
être encore découpé en morceaux que
voilà l'état d'esprit c'est ça qu'est ce
qu'on va devenir
qu'est ce que l'on va devenir claude
françoise saulnier si vous êtes élu dans
quelques jours merde valentigney
comment pouvez-vous rassurer ses
salariés dont on comprend dont on a
entendu la détresse
déjà la première des choses ce qu'a
refusé
monsieur gautier de faire c'est déjà de
recevoir les représentants de ses
salariés au sein du conseil municipal où
ça me paraît très important de pouvoir
entendre cette détresse qui exprime est
effectivement dans le rôle de la mairie
voir comment on peut accompagner
socialement des familles qui pourraient
se retrouver en difficulté
comment pma si nous sommes élus
nous pourrons agir auprès de paix man
mais aussi auprès de nos parlementaires
puisque comme vous l'avez dit peugeot
principale comment commanditaires auprès
de cette entreprise
l'état injecté de l'argent auprès du
groupe peugeot pour maintenir l'activité
et on devoir faire preuve de poids le
plus le plus fort possible pour sauver
cette entreprise lui permettent sa
reconversion
puisque ça va être une question
essentielle pour l'avenir
philippe gautier on entend beaucoup pma
pm1 pma comment préserver les emplois
notamment les emplois industriels et
doit-on se résoudre quand on est élu
avoir finalement s'effilocher le tissu
industriel notamment dans le pays de
montbéliard
je veux permettre de répondre allez-y
parce que vous êtes là pour ça pour
confronter vos points de vue donc
allez-y la nomme sommier non non c'est
inexact ne pouvait pas dire que j'ai
refusé de voir les délégués syndicaux
je ne vois pas d'où vous sortez cette
information ou deux mois elle est très
érodé n'ont cessé cause de mon faux elle
a dix ans si je peux me permettre elle a
dit je vais trop vite mais ça et
municipales tels faits oui madame smith
souhaitait faire un conseil municipal
6,6 pour faire une tribu défaire une
motion qui n'aboutira à rien moi je
préfère être dans l'action que plutôt
des dans l'écriture maintenant je
m'expliquais être dans l'action c'est
déjà et comme vous l'avez dit à juste
titre c'est nos parlementaires
vous n'êtes pas censé savoir que a
ralenti né dans la salle du conseil
justement j'ai reçu le directeur de
peugeot japy j'ai reçu donc le conseil
régional
le sénateur le député le président de
pma le vice président en charge de
l'économie afin de connaître la
situation et ce qui me semble important
et dès le lendemain dans la permanence
de frédéric barbier député la 4e
circonscription en marche
j'aimerais en marche oui mais peu
importe si le député aujourd'hui et
c'est pas l'étiquette politique ils sont
importantes c'est comment fait-on pour
aller justement aller à la sauvegarde de
l'emploi
donc à partir de là et là on a encore vu
est d'ailleurs celui qui parle
savez-vous son nom le syndicaliste moi
je le sais parce que je suis en compter
avec lui je vous dirais simplement que
son prénom ses marques
voilà j'ai
son nom parce que je venais quand même à
la télévision donc ses marques parce que
et pourquoi je le connais parce que je
suis en contact bien et depuis bien
longtemps avec voilà donc la situation
que j'appuie je la connais mais oui oui
vous avez raison il faut travailler et
faire un conseil exceptionnel pour faire
une motion non j'en vois pas l'intérêt
mais maintenant c'est ma vision des
choses je n'avais une autre et je la
respecte et ça me pose aucun souci
maintenant non le tissu industriel ne
doit pas s'effilocher bien évidemment
mais notre marge de manoeuvre est quand
même limité c'est bien l'industrie qui
va décider
c'est comment fait-on pour aider ceux
qui seront qui auront besoin de notre
justin claude françois sommier je vous
laisse répondre et après on passe à
d'autres thématiques
alors moi je veux bien que philippe
gauthier a suivi de près le devenir de
cette entreprise moi je constate six ans
de mandat
50 % de perte des effectifs sur cette
entreprise à valentigney je tire cette
conclusion la rumeur s était est ce que
ça aurait été différent s'il savait
était vous la mer alors je ne lis pas
dans les boules de cristal
assad accusé un élu de la part d'emplois
dans une brise simplement le fait qu'on
ait laissé ces entreprises sans réponse
depuis le mois de février sur
l'engagement qui a été pris par pma de
racheter des locaux pour permettre de
donner de la trésorerie à cette
entreprise
je pense ça que je ne l'aurais pas
laissé faire en tant que maire mais
encore une fois c'est complètement faux
parce que la liquidation judiciaire
n'avait pas été fait et le propriétaire
n'était pas encore fait donc en aucun
cas pema via la sem société d'économie
mixte ne pouvaient acheter les bâtiments
ça ne pouvait se faire qu'à partir de
mercredi dernier seulement voilà